okay ich bin meine nächsten kiste so
original
davos s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge jump liegen heute
haben wir eine richtig geile challenge
am start die idee dazu kommt von der
person nicht nennen werde aber die ist
richtig wir machen sie mit macht mit
einer doppel face com herbert rude boy
und challenge steht heute an keine angst
ich hab mit justin ja vielleicht kennen
einige das video schon dieses snap the
change gemacht es ist verlinkt und wird
falls ihr nicht kennt unbedingt abdecken
und ich springe ein weil die nächste
kiste kommt muss gas geben dank der
folgendermaßen es gibt neue snap chat
feature mit dem man snaps rückwärts
laufen lassen kann und wir machen heute
eine youtuber namen rückwärts laufen
lassen erraten challenge sehr langer
name funktioniert folgendermaßen in den
titel funktioniert folgendermaßen max
spricht einem youtuber namen 1 ins netz
lässt ihn rückwärts laufen dann koche
dann kommt was komisches raus dann
spricht er diese komische nachricht nach
und lässt das wieder rückwärts laufen so
dass es quasi wieder richtig ist aber
anders klingt wenn ich dann erraten hat
dessen was ist dann
dann darf ich natürlich in dieser phase
das ist es wesentlich simpler als
geglaubt
in der vorphase ich mich natürlich dass
sie ja gesagt so lag in der vorauswahl
der kiste ok blanik übernahmen letzte
rückschlag
das rückwärts gelaufen an versucht das
laufen nach zu sprechen
und ja ihr habt richtig
so kann es eigentlich immer den nächsten
1 sprechen ich hoffe weiter ich bin auch
noch was wird sie bei 11% akuter denn
das macht er mit nächste kiste
die kann man also das versteht vom
rückwärts gesprochen
was sie ansprechen musste
daneben esel amok so keine ahnung als
würde ja aber sollte das coole ist wenn
ich maxis fest im spiel habt müsst ihr
euch eigentlich den ton geben können wie
es ein spricht ja du hast du ein spitzen
idee an einer pest jedoch weiter alter
mann mit alles okay ich hab jetzt
natürlich ist gerade die kiste bisschen
vorschnell geöffnet aber diese hier
werde ich jetzt nicht wieder sofort
öffnen
so schreibt einfach mal rein
wir beginnen jetzt mit diesem mit diesem
ich sage es ist sonnig die kiste ist das
egal
und das ist jetzt nummer zwei also nick
fry pixel vor allem dieses dann zeigt
mir einfach auf dem rückwärts gesprochen
der name ist kann es auch machen dann
wird es noch okay und macht den nächsten
geht nicht so schnell verstummen motto
den abwärtstrend ab dem rückwärts
gelaufen
hast du mich hören
original und rückwärts ok ich sage es
ist nummer drei schreibt 1 kommentar wer
das sein könnte ich sage ist es den
jetzt junge jawohl
also falls ihr noch nicht genau wissen
wir das machen könnte macht einfach
einen kommentar auf und schreibt dann
immer so 12345 und wer denkt dass es ist
okay so original phase junge einfach nur
eine food kiste okay halt direkt den
nächsten raus und abgepackt egal
trotzdem gibt es gar der deutschen autos
für tomtom bin richtig gut darin richtig
gut willkommen im kopf von augen die
hong kong private war ich muss hier kurz
immer mitnehmen so oft macht bin noch
nicht bei der kiste leider war
danach haben habe ich einen am start ja
ein schwieriger meine assistentin und
vermittelt hatte der wirt die kurse
teils niemals ok ja warte warte und ich
komme ich noch zur kiste kommen jetzt
die kiste de ist eine kiste die macht
der manager weiter welcher die kisten
öffnung ich geb dir schon mal ein
vorgeschmack
die gc-abwehr zu hell ist die geschärft
du kannst aber das ist voll ist es
vorwärts oder rückwärts
es ist von mir rückwärts gesprochen ja
soll ich dir zeigen richtig umwege
schwärmen na ja das ist auch rückwärts
gelaufen dass noch ein vorwärts laufen
lassen aber bald dpa bb drei steht jetzt
ja okay dann darf ich die nächste kiste
öffnen für die gäste war es nicht
schnell genug war es okay bei stege war
das sage ich und damit auf die eröffnen
okay aber erst wenn ich mich getan habt
ihr okay hier damit auf die kiste
aufmachen aber erstmal okay 12 kekse
aber dass man nicht rausnehmen weil
wieder irgendein präsent mit fünf kisten
öffnungen da dran war
ich bin richtig eklig mit der angel spam
report ist nee ich hab noch keine kiste
ich will dass du es ja okay okay dann
friert machen ok heraus
so und kissel ich weiß es nicht
german letzten germany's play rückwärts
ok und jetzt gebe ich erzähle ich
und je besser man jetzt hört man jetzt
besser aber auf jeden fall macht ich
habe die runde gewonnen danke schön ist
dabei sein möchte wenn ihr aus so eine
sache
eine serie haben wollt vielleicht immer
so eine bruder change mit doppel face
camp schreibt das in die kommentare
hätten wir beide bock drauf dann war es
soweit
dankeschön fürs zuschauen lassen daumen
da wir sehen uns wieder drei märz gut
und 3